what countries are you seeing where the
level of population growing
exponentially is a matching Innovation
and which ones are you seeing that where
the population grows Innovation is
declining what what what trends are you
noticing well I would say that economic
growth is really a combination of
population and freedom so you don't have
to have a growing population uh
necessarily if you're compensating for
it with higher degree of economic
freedom so China starts to liberalize
after 1978 and they have a very high
economic growth rate in fact they are
the most successful economy over the
last say four what the 58 or
1978 China sort of drops hardcore
communism I mean it takes time for them
to liberalize in more areas but but the
point is that during the 1980s and the
1990s for the last 40 years China has
been growing quite rapidly even though
they did have the the one child policy
now my argument would be that if they
didn't have the one child policy they
would be growing even faster
India also has success did a great deal
partly because they started liberalizing
they started having a more capitalist
system after 1991 reforms and India has
never implemented the kinds of draconian
anti-population policies that China has
so those are two success stories Ireland
is another success story the the the
great disappointment over the last 30
years at least must be Japan uh Japan
Japan which which has basically
stagnated but also many countries in
Western Europe
um Italy hasn't seen growth in the last
20 years
um and in places like that how has Italy
not seen growth there are some of the
most attractive people in the world they
should be making babies left and right
look I would assume like when you're
like Italian Stallion you're thinking
Sly all these Attractive people
for them to have that kind of emotional
control Vinnie it's got to be patriotic
it's not right so just okay data I just
sent you pull up the data I just sent
you the link I just sent you where it
shows countries whose population has
grown the most can you go up we can have
actually the leaders bulletin I don't
know if the link I just sent you shows
me a Leader's bullet and do you see
actually the map is quite telling if you
look at a map you see that Africa is the
darkest uh has the darkest view of the
of the car on the map and that's because
um Africa is still growing in fact
Africa is the sub-Saharan Africa is the
only region in the world where women
have more babies than necessary for
replacement level replacement level is
2.1 children per woman per Lifetime and
pretty much everywhere else in the world
can you explain that 2.1 children per
woman per lifetime that's the
replacement level if you want to keep
populations stable you need on average
2.1 children per woman we spoke about
that last yeah and uh and as as you can
see pretty much nowhere else in the
world
um do you have a growing population
except in sub-Saharan Africa so the
question there is why is sub-Saharan
Africa even in spite of its growing
population not generating a lot of
economic growth and the answer is
because they are generally not free uh
if you grow up in the slums of of uh get
a little closer yeah yeah if you grow up
in the slums of Lagos for example uh you
could be a genius kid but there is
simply very little uh that you can do
with your life um you're probably gonna
get a crappy education you're probably
never going to be able to go to
university or Implement your ideas in
the marketplace because you don't have
the capital or whatever so once again I
emphasize that that growth economic
growth Prosperity is an outcome of
population times Freedom so so so is
there any correlation between
um
lack of technology so which country make
like if I look at this uh statistics
from 2012 to 2021 you see what countries
have grown their population the most
okay uh Iraq very interesting not sure
why 37 okay golden lore golden lore
uh Chad Somalia bennin Maldives Uganda
33 Kuwait 27 Afghanistan why are they
increasing at the levels that they're
increasing Qatar a lot of these are
Muslim nations Saudi Arabia Pakistan uh
Israel 18.37 Philippines 17 Iran 16
population growth from 2012 to 2021 on
them grown the most turkey by the way
again a lot of these are Muslim nations
keep going keep going keep going to see
where we go where okay India 11.2
percent Canada 10.7 Costa Rica 994
Switzerland 8.84 Ireland uh right there
uh Mexico eight percent Norway's pretty
much eight percent Brazil seven and a
half percent u.s's population has grown
5.74 since 2012 we're ahead of UK but
keep going I'm trying to see if anybody
okay China's 4.3 they're they're seeming
to have a net negative population in
2022 some of the numbers that I saw
people that are fleeing and leaving
Spain okay now we have negative which
you were talking about Italy minus 0.72
in the last 10 years Japan minus 1.53
uh Armenia 3.23
Ukraine Greece Ukraine is down four
percent Romania is down five percent
keep going keep going keep going
Croatia's down nine percent
Puerto Rico's down 10 percent
uh and then you have at the bottom
Marshall lines okay Puerto Rico Saint
Martin so so when you look at this court
is there anything that says why Muslim
nations are growing faster than others
is there anything we know about that or
no I actually don't know well it's in
the religion in the Quran that got
Muhammad said for them to Spread spread
out as much as they can because their
average I think is three kids but the
majority of the Muslims that we see are
like four or five kids but it's a it's a
it's a it's a religious thing where in
the Quran it says to be flourish and you
know as many kids as you so okay so so
let's let's kind of see if we can come
up with something so one to me you just
said is religion 100 it's in the Quran
what religion as what can we put culture
as because even Mormonism right yeah you
know the moment you have five kids
people ask you if you're Mormon 100 at
four they think they're still maybe you
might be Christian yeah
we're from uh Bountiful Utah yeah so
religion we have culture uh uh do you
notice that the less there is technology
advancement distractions more babies are
being born
is there a correlation between that like
you know how back in the days people
would say well we had 11 kids but
because we had no TV yeah there's
certainly a correlation between
um being a rich country uh and and uh
having fewer babies partly because most
rich countries also have a very high
percentage of women who are in uh
who are in the uh you don't know who are
in the work Workforce
um and um you know staying at home
taking care of children has a much
higher opportunity cost than going and
work in in the marketplace so let's say
that a woman becomes a banker and can
bring in quarter of a million or half a
million dollars a year home uh staying
at home
basically and taking care of children
means that the cost is between quarter
of a million and a half a million right
whereas if you are a woman say for
example in in an African village and you
are not really a part of the official
Workforce but you still work obviously I
mean you work you work at home you're a
homemaker or whatever but you're not
actually bringing bringing in any
monetary income then then the household
is not suffering that kind of
opportunity cost you know what else I'd
want to know I'd want to also know which
countries in the world lead an abortion
is there a way to pull up this data
pretty sure it's gonna be with which
countries in the world lead in abortion
like what are abortion laws in if we can
just pull up
leading what is that talking to the
highest abortion rates annual per
thousand woman so yeah at the top is
Russia Russia wow interesting 53.7 out
of uh but that's all four that's all a
lot has happened since 2011. even even
though it's 2004 look at the Stark
difference between one and two oh yeah
no ridiculous can you scroll in on that
a little bit Vietnam and Russia you know
it's not even close I don't want to know
I want to know who has the least I
guarantee you it's gonna be a left hand
I bet you Mexico is going to be the
number one that doesn't go to the bottom
let's see if the bottom shows are the
opposite Mexico Mexicans are not having
abortions bro they're just like no we're
good that's pretty wild that's dope 0.1
like I told your expertise is AI and
abortion
so then he's moving to Mexico yeah yeah
thank you
can we get into these numbers a little
bit yeah where were you going with this
with the with the abortion I'm trying to
see the the areas that are growing with
more kids so his argument was was that
women higher education they not only
don't want to have more kids they can't
have more kids if you're a career if you
want to make your career a priority over
maybe other places where you're working
but you're working for different reasons
to hear it's more to want to compete so
women is one what else would be the
reason for some of these countries
population to be grown as fast as they
are and some that are not but go ahead
you seem to have a question
well uh
the Russia thing that just throws me for
a loop here I didn't want to go down the
abortion alley over here but that very
interesting how much Russia is leading
the world in abortion do you have any
reason for that you know all of these
things
um you know whether countries are
growing whether they are not whether the
population is declining how many
abortions they have they can have many
different causes
um and and I don't think that we quite
know exactly how they all interact with
each other but Russia is a country which
has had a problem with uh basically
having a very negative view of the
future this has been a case since really
the 1970s China of China Russians have
been suffering from the problem of
alcoholism for a very long time
dying early so there's a lot of stuff
with depression and basically not seeing
Russia as a place that is going anywhere
now one possibility is that you are not
having children partly because of
economic uncertainties but also partly
because uh life generally is is tough
and and and uh and a lot of Russians
just don't see a future for for that
country as opposed to for example Israel
Israel
um the the interesting thing about
Israel is that is that it is a wealthy
country but uh women even though they
are highly educated and they are working
um still keep on having children above
the replacement level and that's not
just the Orthodox Jews but also secular
Jews and one possible explanation that
I've come across is that because Israel
has been growing so fast and and has had
such a positive attitude about its
future for the last 20 or 30 years that
people feel yeah I can I can have a
third baby because the likelihood is
that my income in 10 years time is going
to be much higher than it is right now
now that is not the kind of calculation
that you can make in Russia or in Italy
for that matter
if you believe the future looks bright
order your future looks bright hat today
[Music]